Yesterday's press briefing with Donald Trump
was outrageous.
His mind seemed to sort of turn to mush before
our very eyes with bizarre claim after bizarre
claim.
I'm going to give you very little lead up
and just get right into the clips.
I've gotten some complaints recently, David,
get to the clips, talk about them after.
So let's just do it.
Clip number one.
Yeah.
Please ask your question about you said as
well.
He said that you're planning to issue an executive
order to ensure that health insurance companies
prevent her cover people with preexisting
conditions.
And you said that that had never been done
before.
But that's that's not the case because that
is the law under the Affordable Care Act.
So my question is, why do you need to issue
an order for a law that is already.
I didn't say I said as an executive order.
I, as you said, should as an executive order.
It hasn't been done before.
We want to we want to be able to assure people
that preexisting condition is always taken
care of.
This is truly one of the dumbest things I've
heard Trump say.
And Jeff Mason, you might remember, I just
dealt with this yesterday on the show.
Jeff Mason, the reporter, is spot on.
Preexisting conditions are already covered
in the United States.
They've been covered for 10 years.
They must be covered by health insurance companies.
You can't be denied coverage because of preexisting
conditions, because of Obamacare.
We do not need an executive order for something
that's a law.
And Trump comes up with this idea.
And as you can see, when he's pushed to come
up with stuff on the spot, it doesn't go well.
Trump says, well, I want to redouble it because
it's never been mandated by executive order.
So we just want to be like extra sure.
This is absolutely ridiculous.
This is like saying, you know, murder is only
illegal by law.
We've never outlawed murder by executive order.
We we sort of need an executive order from
a president against murder because otherwise
we only have a law against killing other people.
We don't have an executive order.
I have a hard time imagining a dumber argument
for why you would need an executive order
for something that's already the law.
Tax fraud is only illegal by law.
Why hasn't Trump passed an executive order
saying we are not going to allow tax fraud
in the United States?
It makes it as dumb as it sounds.
Okay, let's continue now on the topic of 160000
American deaths due to coronavirus.
Sixty thousand people have died on President
Obama's watch.
Do you think you would have called for his
resignation?
No, I wouldn't have done that.
I think it's I think it's been amazing what
we've been able to do.
If we didn't close up our country, we would
have had one and a half or two million people
already dead.
We've called it right now.
We don't have to close it.
We understand the disease.
Nobody understood it because nobody's ever
seen anything like this.
So the question is a good one.
If Corona virus hit when Barack Obama was
president and we had 160000 deaths.
Would you, Donald Trump, be calling for the
resignation of Barack Obama?
And Trump says no.
And of course, there's a tweet for everything.
There's actually four or five tweets.
But just to show you one, Donald Trump did
call for Barack Obama's resignation because
one guy with Ebola got into the United States
through an American airport.
Trump tweeted back in 2014, days before the
2014 midterms.
And you might remember that the day after
the 2014 midterms, we never heard another
word about Ebola because it actually was not
an outbreak of any importance in the United
States.
Trump said if this doctor who so recklessly
flew into New York from West Africa has Ebola,
then Obama should apologize to the American
people and resign, but resign over 160000
dead.
No, he would never call for that because why?
It's Trump this time.
That's actually the only difference.
Next again with 1917.
Listen closely to this one.
The closest thing is in 1917, they say.
Right.
The great the great pandemic, as certainly
was a terrible thing, where they lost anywhere
from 50 to 100 million people, probably ended
the Second World War or all the soldiers were
sick.
It was a it was a terrible situation.
And so, again, with the 1917 stuff.
Now, of course, the 1918 flu was in 1918.
We've interviewed historians who are experts
in the 1918 pandemic.
I asked in very clear and simple terms, is
there any logical reason you can think of
why Donald Trump would call it the 1917 flu?
No reason that we can think of.
But then Trump says the 1917 flu, which is
really the 1918 flu, probably ended World
War two.
Now, you if you are even remotely connected
to time and the fact that it moves forward
as far as we know with our human understanding
of it, World War Two was decades after the
1918 flu pandemic.
I can't make any sense of it.
Maybe he meant World War One, which would
also be wrong, but at least it would be in
the ballpark in terms of the right decade.
Trump asked about 100000 kids, nearly 100000
kids testing positive for coronavirus in the
last two weeks of July.
That's a very short period of time.
And Trump insists schools should open.
And yes, he insists that children are basically
immune from the virus.
Ninety seven thousand children tested positive
for the virus in July, according to American
Academy of Pediatrics.
Give you any pause about schools reopening
for in-person because they may have, as you
would call it, a case and maybe a case.
But it's also a case where there's a tiny
it's a tiny fraction of death, tiny fraction,
and they get better very quickly.
Yeah, they have.
They may have it for a short period of time.
But as you know, the the seriousness of it
in terms of what it leads to is is extraordinarily
small, very, very much less than one percent.
I believe they are essentially.
Yeah.
I think that for the most part they do very
well.
I mean, they they don't get very sick.
The truth is that every week we learn more
about kids actually being very efficient carriers
of corona virus.
Now some get very sick.
It's not that common.
That's true.
But kids can be huge vectors of spreading
the disease.
And in fact, there was a I don't know now
if it was like it might have been a some kind
of Christian summer camp.
I remember exactly somewhere in the Midwest
and they had a big outbreak.
And as they tested the kids, the younger cohorts
had more and more corona virus.
So, you know, if you take like the 13 to 17,
they had less than the 12 to, you know, eight
to 12.
And then the really young kids had even more.
So this appears to be completely wrong.
But the facts don't matter.
They really don't matter.
And unfortunately, it's not just Trump that
they don't matter.
They don't matter to his followers either.
So now let's get to Trump's new strategy to
try to say how great we're doing on Corona
virus.
I'm not going to tell you what you're going
to see here, but see if you can spot the strategy.
Bloating the short term in the lab tests,
lab tests take a little bit longer.
And Dr. Burks was tell me a little while ago
that we're down to two days and two and a
half days on getting your result on the lab
test.
The other ones, you get him in five minutes
to 15 minutes.
So that's exciting.
But countries in every continent are seeing
increases in cases in recent days.
Cases have rapidly increased in Japan and
Australia, unfortunately, and they're now
experiencing higher peaks than they did in
March to the south of a border of our border.
Cases have continued to surge in Mexico, Central
America, Argentina, Colombia, Peru, Brazil
and throughout.
Latin America is really the hot spot.
It's posing a major challenge for this continent.
Latin America is now the region with the most
number of confirmed cases by far despite a
relative scarcity of tests.
So Trump mentions Japan and Australia.
Japan and Australia are having second waves.
So everybody's in trouble and the U.S. really
isn't that bad off.
There's actually a lot here to understand.
So first of all, when you look at a country
like Australia, Australia has, as of this
morning, 331 corona virus deaths total.
That number is maybe giving you a double take.
Could that really be true?
Yes.
Total 331 Australians have died from Corona
virus.
We often have 500 deaths in one day, 1000
deaths in one day.
Fifteen hundred deaths in one day.
At the peak, we had even more.
Australia does have.
A recent uptick in cases, but only up to a
few hundred cases per day.
We have 40000 cases a day, 60000 cases a day,
80000 cases a day.
But the real difference is that Australia
has immediately started shutting back down
and extending guidelines, whereas in the United
States, when we have 40, 60, 80000 cases a
day, you get people parroting talking points
like we have a lot of cases because we test
so much.
And we certainly don't need to close anything.
Trump mentioned Japan very similar.
Japan has a population of 125 million.
That's about 35 percent of the population
of the United States.
OK, they have a thousand deaths.
Total, total.
Per capita, Japan's death rate is dramatically
lower than the United States.
And Trump is right.
Japan is seeing more cases over the last 10
days.
They have a fraction of the cases we do per
capita and they are immediately expanding
guidelines and shutting things down.
So comparing the U.S. to Australia and Japan.
First of all, has to be done on a per capita
basis.
But most importantly, they are seeing cases
go up and they are shutting down because they
are taking it seriously.
We are not one little clip here about car
companies.
Check this out.
12 million or 12 million above expectations.
Which is pretty remarkable.
Today, we had great reports on new job openings.
And there's clearly a housing boom, which
has been incredible numbers in both housing
and an automobile boom.
We've rarely seen anything like it.
And it's going on right now in America.
Inventories are at rock bottom.
Used car sales are at record levels.
Then we will have rebuilt.
We're doing a rebuilding like nobody's ever
seen.
It's a big plus for manufacturing and construction.
So construction's getting close to record
territory.
Manufacturing is doing very well.
The car companies are doing great.
Very happy for Michigan to say to Michigan,
we have a lot of car companies moving in.
A lot of plants are being built and expanded
in Michigan and Ohio.
Now, just about everything Trump says there
is a lie, claiming everything is at a record
high constructions that are everyth everything's
just doing better than ever.
But he makes the very specific claim that
car companies are moving into Michigan and
Ohio.
I looked around, I was able to find no evidence
of that.
And, you know, there really aren't that many
automakers.
So when you make a claim like automakers are
just moving into Michigan and Ohio and opening
stuff up, it's really easy to fact check because
there aren't that many automakers, quite frankly.
And again, a provable lie.
Here's one.
Will Barile introduce a little bit more?
Trump got an actual policy question that was
not just kind of rant about Corona virus for
two minutes and he just can't discuss policy
in any depth whatsoever.
He has nothing to say.
This is a Brazilian reporter.
Check this out.
I mean, you have to you can't ambassador in
Brazil to focus his efforts to eliminate ethanol
in Brazil.
We haven't really discussed that too much.
But at some point we probably will be.
And we don't want people terrifying us.
And if they Tarifa.
Although I must tell you, I have a very good
relationship with President Paulson Naro.
He's great.
And I hear he's doing well.
He's recovered from having covered.
Having covered 19, as they say.
And that's great.
And send him my regards.
I think that as far as Brazil is concerned,
if they do tariffs, we have to have an equalization
of tariffs.
And we we are going to be presenting something
having to do with tariffs and fairness and
tariffs, because we have many countries for
many years that have been charging us tariffs.
He just mutters Corona virus, both scenario.
We have a good relationship.
Covered 19, as they say.
Say hello to him for me.
If they do tariffs, we do tariffs.
No ability whatsoever to discuss policy in
detail.
And then here's the last one.
Trump again with his predictions about the
future of Corona virus.
And people should vote like they did in World
War One and World War Two.
And your numbers will be in 90 days or less.
Your numbers will be very good.
I think much better on the Corona virus or
the China virus.
But it's something you have to look about,
look at and say this is just crazy.
This just came out half a million incorrect
ballot applications sent all over the state
of Virginia.
So before changing topic randomly there, Trump
says in 90 days things.
We'll be good.
This is the guy who was it, March or April,
where he said 15 cases are soon going to be
zero.
He has no idea about any of this stuff.
Nothing.
He predicts, can or should be taken seriously.
And you really saw during this press briefing
Donald Trump's mind becoming mush.
There's there's just nothing there.
There's no critical thinking.
There's no analysis.
There's no connection to the facts.
And sadly, as I mentioned earlier in the show,
60, 62 million, 64, 66, maybe 68 million Americans
are going to vote for four more years.
If that doesn't motivate you to vote, regardless
of the state you live in, there's probably
nothing that will motivate you to vote.
We'll have more coverage of this on the David
Pakman show, Instagram, which is at David
Pakman show.
You can follow me there as well at David Pakman,
The
David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.